- [Narrator] With hits like Squid Game,
Don't Look Up, Bridgerton,
and Stranger Things,
Netflix has long been
the leader in streaming,
but in April the company
reported a drop in subscribers
for the first time in a decade.
- We're getting pretty
high market penetration.
And that combined with a competition
is really you know,
what we think is driving
the lower acquisition and lower growth.
- [Narrator] The decline
is uncharted territory
for the company which is
facing growing competition
from other streamers.
- They are maturing,
as other competitors are starting to grow.
- [Narrator] Here are three strategies
that Netflix might try
to break free of their subscriber plateau
and how these methods have
worked for other streamers.
- Oh, that that's, that's terrific.
- [Narrator] One strategy that
Netflix is already working on
is reevaluating how it
creates and acquires content.
- We have to have an Adam
Project and a Bridgerton
every month and to make sure
that that's the expectation
of the service constantly.
- [Narrator] Netflix has a wide library
that continues to grow.
In 2021, it released more
than 500 original programs
according to people familiar
with the company strategy.
But it's led to a mixed bag
of hits and misses for the company.
- Netflix spends upwards
of $20 billion a year
acquiring programming, making programming.
They don't wanna reduce that amount
but they would like to
spend it a little better.
- [Narrator] Consistent quality
content has proven important
for gaining and retaining subscribers.
Disney+ and HBO Max
saw subscription spikes
for big releases like
Hamilton and Wonder Woman '84
but many of those subscribers
canceled their plans
within six months.
- You have to strike a balance
of keeping the machine going
and fresh stuff coming
in without overwhelming
your customer base.
But yes, what you don't want
of course are large periods
between new shows coming out
and or hit shows returning.
- [Narrator] Another avenue
that Netflix has said
they will explore is adding
a cheaper ad-supported option
for subscriptions.
- Netflix has been very
against advertising,
against the idea of advertising,
the co-founder Reed
Hastings has always said
this is a platform built for the viewers,
built for our subscribers.
Our subscribers don't want
ads, ads interrupt the content.
- [Narrator] Most other streamers
already offer ad-supported options.
It's been a staple of
Hulu's plans for years.
Ad-supported subscriptions
make up about 59% of its base.
According data from subscriber
measurement company Antenna.
HBO Max began offering a
9.99 subscription with ads
in June of 2021 compared
to its regular 14.99
ad-free version.
After about six months
ad supported subscriptions
made up about 8% of its base,
according to Antenna.
And Disney+ announced that
they'd release a lower cost
ad-supported option later this year.
A small, but growing number of subscribers
are choosing ad-supported plans.
According to Antenna,
they accounted for 32%
of streaming signups in 2021
compared with only 19% the year before,
which translated into a small increase
in subscriptions as well.
- Of course, what Netflix doesn't wanna do
is see a lot of their current subscribers
who pay a lot of money
to not have commercials
decide economically it's a better bet
to deal with some commercials.
So they're gonna have to balance that out,
but the hope is new
revenue from commercials,
new subscribers coming in.
- [Narrator] Saving money
accounts for about 30%
of subscription cancellations in the U.S.,
according to survey data
from Kantar Entertainment On Demand.
Offering a lower price
might entice more holdouts
who don't wanna pay Netflix's
current lowest plan.
- People are being very
cost conscious these days.
The idea that you cut the cord
and save money through streaming
is a little bit of a myth.
And the more these services go up in price
the more people will realize
it's a bit of a myth.
- [Narrator] The trickiest strategy
Netflix wants to focus on
is cracking down on password sharing,
an issue that streamers have
been trying to solve for years.
- Streamers have a love hate relationship
with password sharing.
Streamers don't want to be the bad cop
cracking down on people
sharing their passwords
but at some point it becomes so widespread
that it affects the bottom line.
- [Narrator] Netflix estimates
that password sharing
is losing them a large
portion of customers.
222 Million households
subscribe worldwide.
But the company estimates
that an additional
100 million households access the service
through shared passwords.
- Viewer penetration is
made up of two groups.
One is a group that's
paying us, which is great.
And then there's a group of
viewers that are not paying us
and they're sharing someone
else's account credential.
And we really see that second group
is a tremendous opportunity.
- [Narrator] Netflix
already has some measures
to prevent password sharing.
There's a limit on the number of profiles
an account can have and
different subscription levels
have caps for how many devices
can be watching at a time.
Other streamers currently
follow similar models.
A new method Netflix might try
is adding an additional
charge for accounts used
in more than one household.
They're already testing
subscription models
like this in Chile, Peru and Costa Rica.
- There are going to be customers upset.
People get used to
getting something for free
or feel like I subscribe,
I should be able to share this with my son
and my daughter who live in another state.
And so they're gonna have to be,
do a good job in explaining
that the only way
we can keep bringing you
all the programming you love
is to have more revenue to make it.
- [Narrator] Whatever
Netflix chooses to do,
the industry will be watching closely.
- With Netflix is going to
to try to be more efficient
or to use their words, right
size their programming budgets,
that has a ripple effect on
the rest of the industry.
I'm sure for the rest of the industry,
they're thinking, great.
These guys have been overpaying
and blowing budgets out
of proportion for years.
So now everything may actually return
to some sort of sense of normal.
- [Narrator] In addition
to these measures,
Netflix will also likely
turn their attention
to international markets like Asia
where streaming is still fairly
new and not yet saturated.
(dramatic music)